eu queria dizer primeiro boa tarde a
todos e contá que eu vou tentar trazer
um pouco essa questão da educação por um
outro viés para a gente tentar entender
porque a gente quer essa mudança na
educação né a gente está falando muito
de uma mudança necessária a gente está
falando muito de novas possibilidades e
por que a gente é isso né porque que
isso está entusiasmando tantas pessoas e
aí eu gosto muito da expressão né perto
da raiz firme nas coisas
o que tá se gestando no mundo hoje é uma
mudança que pode chegar mais perto da
raiz né que pode chegar mais perto da
essência das coisas ea essência das
coisas está a atacar muito no
descobrimento é de cada um e eu gosto
muito de uma história do graciliano
ramos que está no livro chamado
alexandre e outros heróis em conta a
história de alexandre um garoto que
estava andando por uma mata e aí ele ver
uma onça ele sai correndo correndo
correndo correndo e ele chega em casa e
aí ele conversa com o pai dele falou o
pai tudo bem eu estava correndo a de uma
onça eu o pai falou alexandre olha no
espelho e ver o que aconteceu com você
eu alexandre vai lá no espelho ele se
olha ele percebe que ele está sem olho
esquerdo ele perdoa esquerdo na mata e
aí ele ficou muito assustado né porque
perdeu um olho neves e não era fácil ea
ele pensa eu voltar vou tentar resgatar
esse olho perdido quando ele volta
ele começa a buscar a investigar e
tentar entender por onde tinha passado
até que ele consegue encontrar uma
clareira o olho dele lá em cima de um
galho
ele vai lá pega olho passou na manga da
camisa para limpar um pouco que tinha
algumas folhas no olho e ele vai e fecha
os olhos na verdade festa única coisa é
que eu era o que ele tinha e aí coloca o
olho esquerdo
ele tinha pego na mata e aí é muito mau
acho que esse momento porque quando ele
abre os dois olhos
ele percebe que ele cometeu um pequeno
equívoco ele acabou colocando esse olho
ao contrário de um jeito atravessado e
aí quando ele abriu os olhos
ele passou a olhar pra dentro e para
fora ao mesmo tempo ele passou a olhar
uma abundância infinita de dentro de
fora e eu sinto que essa educação que
tanto se quer construir essa educação e
consegue olhar pra dentro pra fora né
essa educação do olhar atravessado
educação consegue chegar perto dessa
raiz da sua essência das coisas e essa
história ela tem muito valor pra mim
porque de alguma maneira foi o fato de o
perceber a abundância que existe no
mundo que me fez perceber a quantidade
de coisas que eu podia que eu posso
fazer
eu nasci numa área de embu das artes em
são paulo que é uma área periférica meus
pais são migrantes nordestinos minha mãe
costureira meu pai pedreiro eu acho que
é uma coisa que acabou fazendo com que
eu crescesse um pouco sufocado durante
muito tempo foi essa interiorização de
um de uma coisa menor né
por vários anos eu fiquei pensando ah eu
sou pobre eu não tenho isso não tem aqui
eu chegava na escola eu ia falar com o
professor o professor falava olha eu
ainda vou ver você você você nas páginas
dos jornais
mas nas páginas policiais e ver esse
tipo de coisa me fazia pensar como assim
né que precariedade é essa
e aí pouco a pouco fui percebendo que
tudo isso era uma escassez artificial né
totalmente artificial uma escassez
inventada pelas pessoas que não estão
percebendo a abundância que está
instalado em todo lugar
e essa abundância ela realmente está
presente ela está presente na professora
por exemplo que encontrei no terceiro
ano do ensino médio que resolveu me dá
um livro de literatura um livro
dostoiévski crime e castigo
meses antes a prestar vestibular e essa
professora sabia que esse livro não é
cair no vestibular mas ela resolveu me
dar
o livro
ela resolveu sugerir que o lesse como um
presente mesmo né
eu sinto que isso de novo é um ato muito
pequeno que traz abundância e pra falar
de abundância é só abrir o olho né
não precisa mais do que isso você abre o
olho você encontra muita coisa e logo
que terminei a faculdade de jornalismo
eu acabei junto com os amigos criando um
projeto que depois culminou no
lançamento desse livro volta ao mundo em
três escolas
e esse livro ele conta histórias de
escolas de ongs de universidades que
estão no brasil em outros oito países
fazendo muitas inovações fazendo muitos
processos significativos acontecerem
a gente foi pra outros países porque a
gente sabe que hoje em dia o mundo é
realmente muda a conexão né porque não
potencializar as conexões possíveis mas
o fato de a gente ter ido fora não quer
dizer que a gente não percebeu que a nu
dentro né
muitas buscas foram feitas no brasil e
encontramos muitas coisas em são paulo
no rio em minas gerais em vários outros
estados
e tudo isso só provou que olhar de perto
e tentar encontrar o que está próxima a
mudança que está próxima acaba trazendo
muitas respostas muitos caminhos
possíveis
e aí a partir de agora eu vou falar
sobre três pontos principais que eu
acabei aprendendo
nessa jornada e que eu acabei aprendendo
com os meus pais
com essa precariedade com essa
abundância que eu vejo no mundo e acabei
aprendendo também com o escritor um
pensador chamado elias canetti que fala
muito sobre o poder que fala muito sobre
poesia também e eu vou dividir em três
pontos porque o que eu vou falar a
partir de agora são as características
que eu vi e educadores em pessoas que
estão tentando transformar a educação eo
mundo ao seu redor
características muito fortes nessas
pessoas e características que eu penso
que são muito importantes para as
pessoas que querem criar algo de
seguinte significativo no mundo hoje
criar algo que realmente tem um valor
compartilhado ea primeira característica
é essa de se aproximar do presente se
aproximar do próprio tempo e elias
canetti ele faz uma metáfora muito
interessante que a do cachorro
ele fala de como a gente deveria se
aproximar do nosso tempo como se a gente
fosse um cachorro mesmo farejando os
lugares colocando nosso esforço em todos
os espaços que a gente encontrar pra
gente tentar entender o que está
acontecendo né
é tentar sentir tentar entrar em contato
com o que está acontecendo e o contato
ele só se faz se a gente vai né
preciso desse movimento de entrega e
acho que esse contato ele se dá por
exemplo quando você está numa praça e eu
tenho uma história muito forte que
aconteceu recentemente estava numa praça
numa área em que está atuando agora lá
em são paulo no centro de são paulo e eu
estava simplesmente sentado com o amigo
conversando sobre o nosso projeto e
apareceu um garoto de 12 anos eu fui
descobrir depois ele sentou lá perto e
apontou que tinha mais baratas no banco
aí a gente já falou olha só tem mais
baratas por aqui mesmo assim a gente
continua por lá e é esse garoto pegou e
falou assim hoje eu ia trazer o meu
skate pra ficar andando aqui na praça
mas não trazer
eu vim pra refletir em nossas ver para
refletir o que conta mais é o que você
venha refletir aqui e aí ele começou a
contar que ele era um novo homem
aos 12 anos porque tinha largado as
drogas
e aí eu comecei a conversar com ele
perguntei um monte de coisas
apareceu um morador de rua nesse meio
tempo começou a conversar com a gente
esse morador de rua tinha visto que esse
primeiro garoto de 12 anos tinha deixado
um livro do lado dele no banco e jogado
ao mar de roupa pegou o livro e falou
livro não se deixa jogado livro se deixa
assim e colocou perto do coração e aí ao
mesmo tempo conversar com o pessoal de
12 anos eu perguntei pra ele tem algum
espaço que te traz alegria next traz
felicidade porque está fazendo que a
escola é um lugar chato e ponto ele deu
muitos elogios para a igreja quer um
lugar que estava certa forma apoiando
ele bastante nesse movimento de mudança
e ele falou que um outro lugar
sentia muito feliz era o palco eu
perguntei o palco olha só porque ele
falou porque eu gosto de cantar e eu
gosto de escrever música eu pergunto mas
a escola escola está absorvendo alguma
coisa disso não há escola é chata e aí
eu acho que essa história é importante
não só pelos elementos que esse cara de
trás mas porque de novo né essa
aproximação da realidade eu só conversei
com esse com esse garoto porque eu
estava lá como um cachorro mesmo a
legenda tudo tentando entender se alguém
estava disposto a falar alguma coisa
comigo
um segundo ponto que a outra
característica dessa dessas que pode
realmente fazer com que a gente faça um
trabalho significativo é essa de a gente
se aproximar do presente e tentar
entender o presente
essa primeira que eu falei é se
aproximar e essa segunda é tentar
entender e eu gosto muito quando elias
canetti diz que esse entendimento
ele não é só um entendimento do
superficial né porque às vezes a gente
está transitando em vários mundos e
transitando no mundo da inovação da
mudança mas a gente ainda está vestindo
muitas máscaras né ainda existe muita
mentira nesse mundo da inovação nesse
mundo a mudança às vezes existe mais uma
maquiagem é que está tentando ser feita
do que uma mudança real que vai na raiz
e elias canetti fala sobre o olhar que
tenta entender o que a adversária né
o que há de universal no presente o que
há que acontece hoje e que aconteceu
ontem que vai acontecer amanhã que tem a
ver com humano né porque tem um ser
humano por trás desse processo tanto que
acontecem
e aí eu conto uma história que eu vi lá
em araçuaí no vale do jequitinhonha
minas gerais brasil
o vale do jequitinhonha boa parte vocês
deve conhecer como vai da miséria porque
esse vale é divulgado na imprensa assim
né
mas se você chega lá e começa a farejar
lugar e começa a sentir lugar com mais
profundidade vai perceber que lá existe
um vai do impedimento
lá um dos educadores mais forte da
região tinham rocha
ele fala que o que acontece lá é
impedimento nem empoderamento porque lá
eles conseguem absorver as
potencialidades de cada um e aí aqui uma
foto do ser criança que é um projeto
tocado pelo tinham roche toda a equipe
dele na nesse centro popular de cultura
desenvolvimento cpcd e lanús ser criança
as crianças elas aprendem a ler ea
escrever
de um jeito muito simples a partir de
uma proposta que veio de uma mulher que
mora na região
a dona maria um dia eu te amo estava
conversando com a dona maria e ele
perguntou pra ela olha dona maria a
senhora sabe alguma coisa alguma
habilidade alguma ideia que pode ser
compartilhada com os nossos meninos do
projeto para que eles aprendam alguma
coisa e é dona maria respondeu mesmo
assim ah não sei de nada não sou
fraquinho não sei não sei
e eu tinham claro que sabe alguma coisa
não é possível você não saiba nada ela
falou olhando eu sei fazer um biscoito e
eu te amo conta mais biscoito e aí ela
olha esse biscoitos com o supersimples
vai com um vilão leite ovos mistura tudo
e aí depois você coloca num saquinho
corta a ponta mas nos caminhões a
bandeja coloca no forno tira e está
pronto e último olha que legal né então
dá pra gente usar essa receita lá no
nosso projeto dá pra gente pegar isso e
mostrar para as crianças
e aí quando tinha estava saindo essa
mulher pegou e falou olha e tem uma
coisa importante também o nome do
biscoito o biscoito se chama biscoito
escrevido e aí eu tinha o nosso mesmos
que escrevi dela é porque dá pra
escrever letra número da pesquisa o que
quiser com este biscoito e aí hoje em
dia quando se chega nessa criança você
encontra as crianças no momento
abiscoitado que é o momento onde elas
estão aprendendo a ler e escrever de um
jeito divertido 80 é um fato bem
interessante lá que é um dia em que o
joão o josé na verdade estava sentado lá
num degrau perto lugar estava com sangue
infectado estava meio triste e aí o joão
josé
aí é só josé
vocês vão entender porque eu estou
confundindo porque os dois nomes em
quatro letras joão ele foi conversar com
o tião rocha e tiago rocha
olha só eu de novo é porque são quatro
letras josé foi conversar com tião rocha
eu tinha que falar assim mas pizzi está
triste josé e aí o josé é porque você
sabe né tem essa regra ea gente primeiro
comeu os biscoitos que são as letras
nosso nome né meu nome é josé quatro
letras
imagine meu amigo se chama welinton
imagine a quantidade de biscoito que ele
vai comer né
josé joão quatro letras muito difícil
ver respeitada com esse nome aí o time
pegou e falou assim olha menino você
pode lá se pode escrever o nome da sua
tia de seu avô o seu sobrenome o que for
o que acha simbólico no processo do cpcd
no processo de biscoito ada é que ele
está pegando algo de universal na
realidade que é o saber popular o chão
ele vai lá e bati na porta das pessoas
que estão ao redor da escola pergunta o
que que vocês sabem que pode agregar por
nossos processos e isso é não só está
tentando olhar e fareja o presente mas é
também tentar entender o que exige
profundo mesmo presente né
o que as pessoas trazem com elas que é
realmente relevante que pode realmente
irá trocas muito significativas e aí eu
falei sobre planejar esse momento atual
sobre tentar entender o que há de
universal e significativo no hoje e
agora vou falar sobre a terceira
característica que é agente negar esse
mundo doente de um jeito criativo
criando e aí aqui eu tenho um exemplo
muito claro de escolas na argentina
essas escolas experimentais elas têm uma
dinâmica totalmente diferente é um
exemplo que nega toda essa burocracia
que a gente tem hoje criando algo muito
relevante pra vocês terem uma idéia nas
escolas experimentais não tem nada além
de educadores e alunos
eles não têm coordenadores eles não têm
em merendeiras eles não têm faxineiras
eles têm pessoas que juntas dividem
tarefas porque eles tenham esse esse
ponto do compartilhar lá se compartilha
as tarefas lá se compartilha o silêncio
lá se compartilha o aprendizado
então quando você chega lá e vi uma
estrutura totalmente diferente sendo
gestadas sendo gerida por pessoas que
estão fazendo isso com qualidade né
não é algo que você chega lá e você
encontra o educador todo sujo
lá no canto fazendo as coisas e depois
correndo pra dar aula não é uma coisa
assim
é uma coisa muito baseada mesmo nesse
nessa sensibilidade humana é de como a
gente consegue viver juntos no espaço e
dividir esse espaço com qualidade e esse
é o ponto comum que a gente consegue
negar esse mundo doente que a gente sabe
que está muito bem distribuído por aí
de um jeito criativo né e aí já
encaminhando para o final
tudo isso certa forma se liga muito há
uma percepção que é muito forte para mim
que ficou muito forte depois dessa
jornada do livro e de toda essa jornada
minha educação que é a seguinte
educação não é encher baldes educação é
acender fogueiras
essa frase uma frase que não tem um
autor conhecido mas que tem um
significado muito forte né
a educação que enche baldes e educação
daqueles que acreditam que existe alguém
que sabe existe alguém que não sabe se
existe alguém que vai jogar algo dentro
do outro né existe um balde que é menor
que outro balde e dá pra separar os
baldes dá pra colocar um rótulo no balde
a educação do acendimento de fogueiras é
essa que realmente vai na curiosidade
que realmente vai na paixão né quem
realmente vai onde as pessoas realmente
conseguem se conectar com elas mas
profundamente se conectar com os outros
mas profundamente e perceber a
capacidade delas né porque a capacidade
de cada um é muito grande
quando eu estava na índia visitando uma
escola pública lá eu abrir um livro
encontrei uma história muito muito
a especial era a história de um coelho
estava passando também numa floresta ea
ele encontrou um buraco e ele olhou pro
buraco e vi um sapo lá dentro
esse sapo gritava ele não conseguia sair
do buraco de jeito nenhum e eu com ele
falou para um pouquinho que eu vou
buscar uma escada na minha casa e aí eu
volto e aí você consegue salvar
e aí quando o coelho voltou um tempo
depois que tive lá na casa deles super
land buscar tal da da escada
ele chega olha lá no buraco não encontra
mais nada não encontra mais o sapo
ele procura e ele vê um sapo gritando lá
do alto de uma árvore e fala como assim
sapo um minuto atrás você estava dentro
desse buraco não conseguiu sair e agora
você está lá longe
agora preciso de uma corda de alguma
coisa vai conseguir tirar daí eu só
falou
sabe o que aconteceu quando estava no
buraco uma cobra apareceu e aí eu tive
que juntar todas as minhas forças e dar
um salto
o salto dos autos o salto maior que eu
conseguir fazer e aí eu desse salto
eu acho que esse ponto é muito
importante ele resume toda a minha fala
como que a gente consegue perceber a
nossa capacidade
antes de uma cobra parecer da mulher a
gente como que é possível descobrir o
que dá pra mudar no mundo sem esperar
que o mundo entrou em colapso né
e descobri isso de verdade tocando a
raiz das coisas e não só criando mais
mentiras para a gente mesmo e é muito
importante a gente ficar ligado nisso
não queremos mais ilusões né já tem
muita ilusão no mundo só pra fechar hoje
em dia estou me dedicando bastante para
um outro movimento que se chama
movimento entusiasmo eu acredito muito
que é importante levar entusiasmo da
educação compartilhar entusiasmo para
que a gente junto consigo construir as
coisas e espero que vocês continuem
entusiasmados a gente consiga construir
algo junto com o movimento muito intenso
acontecendo na gente olhando
pra fora e olhando pra dentro ao mesmo
tempo muito obrigado